In addition to the rash, I seem to be retaining fluid, arms, legs, face, cuffie. Could this be related to kidney function or allergic reaction or other?
So when you're retaining fluids and you're getting cuffiness, you think of things like, okay, is there blocked, lymphatic?
Certainly, if you're getting fluid in your face, your face is getting cuffied and your arms and legs, then you don't think so much lymphatic.
So you think lymphatic is if both your legs are swelling or your one arm is swelling after surgery or something like that, there's a blocked lymphatic drainage.
When you have more systemic fluid, you think of things like allergy to something and when you have systemic inflammation like that, you think that I can reaction to a medication.
That's what I would think of.
Certainly kidney function. So you're on the right track with that. Your kidneys are what drain that and certainly kidney function could affect that too.
I would definitely get some blood work to make sure your kidney function is within normal limits and that's cleared up.
Okay, sorry, it's finished. That's probably blood work yesterday, but if sinophils are high, so what will raise you sinophils?
Is different parasitic infections, fungal infections, most common thing they raise is if sinophils is allergic reaction.
So parasitic infections, fungal infections, you don't think that that ties to increase and retain retention and fluid.
So that doesn't fit the piece there in allergic reaction, certainly ties into retained fluid and elevated the acid of those.
So I'd be concerned about possible reaction to a medication.
So a person can have so let's say a person's not on any medication whatsoever and they go in for a blood test and let's say they have really bad allergy issues, let's say like
you know allergies to pollen or something like that seasonal allergies, and they get a standard CBC done, you know, at a physical they can have elevated just slightly elevated eosinophils that has to do with that that allergy that they're their seasonal allergies.
If a person doesn't isn't probe the seasonal allergies has never known to have elevated eosinophils at different times in the year.
There are on different medications and they have elevated eosinophils plus the retention of fluid, I would definitely talk to the prescribing doctor about possible reaction to a medication.
As far as what relief you could do to that always you want to find the reason why so you want to do what I just said and check it to talk to your prescribing doctor about that.
As far as you got to figure out the reason why first before you start trying to solve the problem.